[Music]
summer is sadly coming to an end but
Hilary Duff is still giving us major
feet spot goals it's about to go down
the younger actress was spotted enjoying
Labor Day in Malibu California with her
five-year-old son Luca and ex-hubby Mike
Comrie and boy did she play what check
out this photo of Hilary frolicking in
the ocean and looking absolutely
flawless in a black bikini paired with
bangle bracelets and a watch with her
long blonde locks down under toned tummy
on full display the 29 year old gave off
some serious mermaid vibes
obviously we live in a world that's
obsessed with bodies and especially in
my industry now hilary admits those
killer abs didn't just appear overnight
working out is something that I need to
do for my my like happiness in fact just
this weekend she put her endurance to
the test
teaming up with her ex rise nation
founder Jason Walsh to raise money for
her hometown of Houston Duff
instagrammed this post-workout snap with
the caption charity climb for the land
that I love
you're really not cute Lee leaves but
it's a great thing because you're
sweating so much the climbing workout is
one of our all-time favorites I feel
like it's really changed my body